today on our show suicide is painless
right we're going to talk about the
Suicide Squad trailer all day long today
you're on fat man on Batman
no gum do Fatman I'm Batman I'm Kevin
Smith I'm mark barnard okay so the MTV
Movie Awards that was a TV movie Awards
the most important Awards in the award
sir can't believe I forgot the name
because I've been trying to win one
forever they they have happened and we
know this because this footage came from
that there's a few things right yeah big
one was fantastic beasts drop the thing
they clip from Civil War dropped and
then and then of course the Iggy was
suicide cursory when I had the entire
cast there they brought everybody out
the big guns and the little guns and the
swords and everything man to drop this
trailer a third trailer
yeah held up two fingers but I meant
three now the Suicide Squad trailers had
been impeccable like me come on the
first one I'm trying to remember what it
was that was the one at the like that
that was the one with I started a joke
yeah I thought the Bohemian Rhapsody one
was better Bohemian Rhapsody one was one
of the best trailers ever cut yeah in
the history of trailers I would say I'll
go out there and [ __ ] plant that flag
yeah like just the first Suicide Squad
trailer rig flag if you will I like the
first job I thought the second shot was
brilliant and I thought this trailer was
wonderful about high-energy again I
don't like I'm for it I'm seeing this
movie I [ __ ] love it but as much as I
want to see as much as they'll show me
mm-hmm
that I'm seeing a lot of this movie man
like throttle back a bit like they want
to keep showing me that's [ __ ] fine
because again I'm gonna go regardless
they got my money but it feels like like
I remember it and when I want to see
Batman V Superman it's like I've
literally seen every scene in this movie
represented in the trailer in large or
small form now we're seeing lots in this
and this movie is still four months away
and we know that they've gone back to
shoot it's not for what everyone thought
it was supposed to be an online guy said
like it was [ __ ] the put jokes in it
but David Ayer they would
more to himself yeah the warrant just
like the movie so much that what else do
you want and there's a yeah and that's
what it was kind of backed up about a
guy plays Captain Boomerang Jai Courtney
his gyre JJ well hi I'm hi guy
he was he gave an interview or somebody
asked him hey are you guys we should and
he said yeah but not for Laughs we're
just making we're put new action
sequences yeah we're just making better
but that all being said like there's a
lot of footage in this third trailer
alone I'm seeing things that I didn't
see in the previous two trailers and
I've seen a lot in those previous two
trailers yeah so none of the visuals
like you know sometimes you watch a
trailer boy they keep cutting from that
same scene and stuff this is taking
liberally it looks like from throughout
a very visceral film like the residents
look and I characters like just throw
away shots like that we're like [ __ ]
they spent a couple hundred bucks I'm
all for they want to keep hitting me
with all that footage it doesn't turn me
off in the lace it makes me want to see
it more but how don't you feel like
you've seen a lot of the movie I don't
even know what the plot is though other
than like they're sending them somewhere
on a mission I mean I know what Task
Force X is and stuff but what is does
anyone know what the specific mission is
yet I don't think so not that I've heard
and it's not go get the Joker it is not
go get it seems like as played out in
this trailer like he's a ranked a monkey
in the wrench if you will yes their
operation yeah I mean whatever that
knows him yeah June moon the sorceress
yeah Beatrice the enchantress rather
keep calling me sorceress yes she's so
the missions about her don't yell but
otherwise they can't hear yes so it's
not the Joker's not the mission no but
we see a [ __ ] ton of Joker in this and a
[ __ ] ton of Harley Quinn
yeah well rightfully [ __ ] so it seems
to be her movie
bernd [ __ ] joker burn victims over
half of the space [ __ ] burned like
how do you show up in the next movie
unless you're gonna keep wearing that
burn like they're [ __ ] this guy up
and I kind of like it's weird now we've
been seeing so much footage of him I'm
kind of used to him as the Joker might
be a smart thing that they did like you
know Heath Ledger's is the Joker that
you gotta somehow match or come close to
or something like that but they've done
enough with him in the trailers now
where I'm like let's see this guy's
beliefs gangster ish like oh yeah like
and I remember first image I saw him the
tats and stuff was like well he was
great in Dallas buyers club like
excellent actor and a few of the vocal
things we heard I was like well that's a
way to go yeah but by this trailer they
put in so much of the Joker and so much
of it looks really [ __ ] cool like not
[ __ ] that you've seen before it's like
Joker as Scarface yes once again best
writer in the room just one [ __ ] job
it is kind of like Joker Scarface bucks
engine yes decadence yeah speeding
around count cars own a big cargo it
looks like a Lamborghini oh yeah but
like the kind of Lambo that like Arab
Prince's have just that weird mirrored
paint shift where zygarde I guess that's
what you will offended because that's
what my car looks like right now but I
think is you're an Arab Prince there it
is that that sequence of course has all
the Batman in it on the roof and we saw
that footage like before a little bit
yeah but there's new Batman footage and
I've been off the building holy [ __ ]
dude yeah like I've got any better flick
that guy looks thin Ben Affleck's heavy
but he was big jacked
so what do you think this is bad stunts
I'm allergic to Anto right there well
[ __ ] Toronto Sun represent forgot to
go back to that Batman this is just
stunt double right or do you think it's
part of the plot unless there's like
somebody there Batman that's what I
thought maybe you know what I'm saying
but everyone got excited cuz he's got a
rebreather in his mouth and it ties into
some mile X maybe no the hush mmm in the
Catwoman issue of hush like he goes into
the water same way dives with with the
Bri breather and stuff I saw a lot of
those panel comparisons but there's a
shot of what looks like that man
carrying Harley Quinn to the Batmobile
like that I'm telling you [ __ ] like that
I was like oh my god oh my god like
we're seeing it in live-action that
would mean that Ben Affleck scary Margot
Robbie yeah like the world's getting
connected now it's very exciting for me
don't know why I got so [ __ ] tight
now I was like oh [ __ ] like more batman
and trailers good thing that must be a
reaction to like i'm sure like everyone
makes that much money just so i can
induce more batman that's and everyone
whenever they talk about Batman V
Superman they're like but [ __ ] Ben
Affleck rules so smartest thing in the
world they did was like [ __ ] your mom
back put a little more in there man a
little more Batman shots cuz that's dope
that shot I am carrying the fact like I
was going anyway but even if that's the
worst moment in the movie I'm going
twice that's just [ __ ] dope man like
[ __ ] like that I like this guy David
Eyre err err we're gonna be there it's
good [ __ ] he's you're not [ __ ]
good he's amazing [ __ ] director
anybody make a tank movie interesting
World War 2 tags movies yeah what goes
in a can
come on dude like I know I just is
saying that and I think you were like
yes good flush you see that [ __ ] good
flick this looks fantastic what else is
in the trailer that we saw that's a Will
Smith a lot of Will Smith you know I'm
sometimes in a mask sometimes most of
the times just long my shirtless is my
biggest question mark about this movie
was always like how does Will Smith play
along with others like at this point
like he hasn't been in an ensemble
since Independence Day oh good point so
it's like how does this
who is still one of the bigger movie
stars on the planet share the space with
Task Force X and it seems like he's
having fun he does that's it seems like
he's having a good time there's no
pressure of like you're the lead dude
look it's all on you yeah you're just
one of a lot dude yeah there's an
excellent [ __ ] parallel with
independent stats couldn't join them he
does seem like he's having a good time
more mass though come on dude because
you did [ __ ] Deadshot do that thing
and it feels like he's gonna stick
around mmm so if that's the case maybe
they get to that silver man from the
comics do you think they make another
one of these services they're worn done
sues that squad do you oh it looks I
mean I was the guy that was like Batman
V Superman can make two million two
billion back when they announced it and
stuff and it doesn't look like it's
gonna get to a billion so take this with
a grain of salt but like how does this
movie not [ __ ] warrant a sequel this
trailer alone warrants an entire sequel
to whatever the [ __ ] they're cooking up
over there it looks [ __ ] fabulous
looks really great so there's no way I
don't think they don't you know not good
or whatever the [ __ ] would no way they
don't [ __ ] go to sequel they pick two
dates in the distant future like I'm now
title DC movies and people are
theorizing that one is the Ben Affleck
Batman Ben Affleck directed Batman solo
movie and then the other will be squad -
yeah come on they know they got
something there and I can't imagine
squad cost as much as Batman V Superman
so there's probably more else imagine
like if they spend more than they had
spent poorly and this seems like you
know this could do I mean I do you don't
want to say Deadpool business but it
feels like it can do Deadpool business
maybe I mean Deadpool Deadpool all it
cost less than this movie though yeah
I'm sure this movie feels like it's like
a hundred million dollars whereas
Deadpool was like 40 worth every [ __ ]
penny oh my god like some of the shots
are [ __ ] unreal dude and it's like
again it seems like there's a element of
joy to this movie thankfully people are
at least the trailers are cut like that
but it seems like the villains are at
least having a good time
you know saying that's what we need died
early in the DC Universe assumed Lex
Luthor was enjoying himself quite a bit
how come he's not in fast for sex you
would think right he is that guy can't
they feel smart yeah man it is it's good
to see DC Universe coming more to life
than what we I mean think about it
that's let's make a statement to because
we're in a year we've just seen Lex
Luthor doomsday Wonder Woman and a brand
new Batman and a new Alfred like you
know we've seen a handful big big the
big DC characters come out man and now
it's being underlined with this their
nestlings they're investing deep if it
was dawn of justice this is like dawn of
injustice right very medal copyright
thoughts overall on the trailer
overall thoughts I liked it definitely
more than the first trailer I feel like
they're they're going a little bit too
quickly to the here's a pop song that
you love and by the way that pop song is
probably from Wayne's World yeah Tia
Carrere sing ballroom blitz on stage at
some point I'm not entirely I'm sure
that wasn't a big wasn't a matter dude
they could have put out the [ __ ] Buck
Owens version of following blitz if
there was one you go look that up kids
and it's still you couldn't [ __ ] with
that trailers yes cut within an inch of
its life perfectly it's just like babe
it's a barrage a [ __ ] you know
everyone thought when they talked about
Zack Snyder Superman they're like he's a
master of the compliment David's imagery
is no [ __ ] slouch by any stretch of
the imagination he liked all that looks
like comic books that I've read come to
life yeah and it feels like he's a
better sort of montage artist like he is
very much about the montage jazz art
where Schneider is very much about the
tableau yes
you know like he's pasty worse that
stuff Schneider does double-page spreads
and it feels like David is doing like
I'm gonna get eight panels on this page
totally twenty on this page there's so
much action go yeah it's very much they
like the the sixteenth grid that Frank
Miller was working on in Dark Knight
just just only on this show with that
[ __ ] reference fly well anybody know
what words are gonna surely man it is
alright so but the ending was strange
I've had not bad but strange and as much
as they focused on Diablo mmm they
really seemed to be like fire good put a
light on him in such a way where I was
like did that guy just suddenly get
famous or something like I thought it
was Justin Bieber the way they were like
but I guess maybe he just hadn't been in
the trailer so much so like fire thing
or he just you know he gets to tee up a
good Harley line basically which is her
saying I used to was yeah yeah she
steals this [ __ ] truck I like here's
the thing let's say everything went
[ __ ] wrong and Suicide Squad only
made like [ __ ] 200 million bucks she
definitely gets a Harley Quinn spin-off
by herself
yes no way that I mean she could [ __ ]
carry good for her that she's in this
ensemble but everything we've seen so
far she'd carry her own [ __ ] movie
yeah she's just a charm factory dude I
mean we all know and love that part but
like come on look at that do you think
that there's a world look at she's
holding the [ __ ] mallet dude she has
a giant mallet my whole life they've
been holding giant mallets of these
[ __ ] books there's one in real life
in fat damn if you live long enough I
got my got that bat in my house and I
know you do
yeah what up son do you think there's a
world in which she gets award
recognition for this um yeah like
absolutely I'm not going to say like
she'll hold an Oscar but like Johnny
Depp was nominated for for playing Jack
Sparrow yeah at one point he Fletcher
was nominated for playing playing the
[ __ ] out of the Joker yeah so you know
maybe man why not like definitely
critics groups and awards circles you
know the big gold I don't know
[ __ ] easily Golden Globe nod yeah
yeah like I'm knowing the Golden Globe
people the way they don't love her and
this and then her performance in the
movie even if they don't like the movie
I think they would go for her in a big
big way yeah what I call in it she's
gonna win an award she's gonna win like
Best Actress on the globe yeah or
something from Musical or Comedy because
that's how they classify this because
this is a neck strain of drama well it's
not a drama so it's definitely gonna be
musical comedy um and it's it's she's
from what I've seen in that trailer just
all these trailers crushed it that's a
tall order dude tall order
[ __ ] fill the spandex were in this
movie she wearing very touchy-feely
she's at one point Jesus they tall order
step into those legendary and colors of
Harley Quinn she's crushing it dude yeah
and honestly like [ __ ] I'm telling
you man like that Leto Joker's growing
on me like if they do it as as what I'm
like based on what I've seen in the
trailers I'm like that Planum as Mark
said kind of like [ __ ] Scarface he's
a mob boss and he's also think about it
this is the first time in a movie that
the Joker's not the big [ __ ] deal
like when he was with Tim Burton's
Batman it's just that's your villain
gosh movie
if you're in Tim you know if you're in
Chris Nolan's Dark Knight
that's your villain you one villain not
your bad guy he's one of many and he's
not even the main villain in this
[ __ ] thing we don't even know who it
is yet it's smart playing cuz then could
lay them a sous on of him men and see
how it plays rather than pock committing
to a whole [ __ ] movie and stuff like
that where people like the Joker again
but they're using them sparingly and
they're using them in innovative ways
that we haven't seen them used in movies
before I recognize some of the imagery
from comics but I've not seen it in the
movies before and I know you haven't
either yeah I would love to see here's
what I want
here we go get missing go I want the
Joker Harley Quinn movie like Sid Nancy
well you didn't see was my eye threw up
in my mouth a little not because I was
disgusted but because I was disgusted
with myself that I hadn't thought of
that because
good idea I want that real man it's like
if you're gonna do a spin-off I want
that there's a moment in the trailer
where you know hear hear him like
laughing and then she goes oh like I got
chills dude like that they were
multiplying that was crazy
to actually like she it's Harley Quinn
acknowledging her [ __ ] up relationship
prior to this but there it is
prior to there's the so she got oh yeah
prior to that moment with the [ __ ]
Joker's like that says [ __ ] ton about
history Kevin Smith makes this movie
he writes nine pages of dialogue about
how she feels about the Joker inside
they [ __ ] one sugar just going oh yeah
Oh [ __ ] that was like if I if I get
the Sid Nancy Meads Natural Born Killers
like road romance between those two
characters know and wash the [ __ ] out of
that good point man let's see who else
katana there's a lot more katana in this
trailer a lot less guy Courtney
no I say there was a little Morgan I
think I mean like its last trailer he
pops the can open and stuff there's the
[ __ ] soul sword dude soul taker sword
but I think I don't know I got the
impression he was in this trailer Bunch
I felt like there was a my god yeah a
lot with her yeah but that's the moment
so you had a girlfriend and then that
might be the last time you see this is
his uh this is his big moment right
Chuck Courtney is that a lot of what the
fights about that that is a dude who
gets more chances and this than anybody
else must have a lot of pictures of
people naked doing horrible things to
each other using that die hard in Russia
movie was he played like beta McClane
he's in the Terminator look how he's
yeah like he's had like nine or ten
different shots at this there it isn't
Jack Reacher he's gonna make that's
right he was in [ __ ] Jack Reed yeah
this is about this come on dude he's
Captain Boomerang this one's gonna work
I felt a sense that has never been said
before this is it he's Captain boring
that's like let's say nobody's ever
connected with him there's other movies
before Annie must have an audience
because they keep [ __ ] using them and
stuff but let's say he hasn't had the
big breakout thing that seems like the
kind of role that could break a guy out
cuz you just got some jokes to tell he
doesn't have to carry the whole movie
nobody gonna be like job of cleaning I'm
whole not this [ __ ] this movie's
gonna work it's gonna work in a big bad
wigs these trailers are working you
better work girl in a big bad way Viola
Davis we got to see a little bit more of
her she's always ready to throw them
under the bus
a lot of rick flagg in this trip yeah
got a bit of rick flagg
we got to hit down a little bit as well
but again there's no clear like this is
the mission yeah holding on to that
there bean and it's very much like the
think it has something to do with BBS
like do they send him to like you know
[ __ ] gotham or i don't know i mean
they they start it like the trailer
opens with the what do we do if Superman
decides to destroy the White House which
is nice directly ties into yeah Batman V
so although which is weird because
spoilers Superman is allegedly dead at
the end of that movie Coto it's who shot
two shot mmm good point I thought about
like sir why they concerned about
Superman it he they just buried him you
know unless this is one of those things
that is a simultaneous storytelling
where this is happening concurrent to
Superman V doomsday okay now hold on
that's exciting so the same way that the
opening of Radiesse mmm-hmm had like the
last 20 minutes of [ __ ] Man of Steel
right you're saying that this could
possibly overlap like maybe the mission
that they send them in is like [ __ ]
right like maybe the African Siddhant in
the beginning is the trigger for is like
listen this guy just went to Africa and
blew up a bunch of people like maybe we
need to have some kind of deterrent
again why they pick these eight
chuckleheads I don't know
but not now I would like that very much
if it tied into the movie vs like that
like if that was DC signature things
like the last 20 minutes were the first
20 minutes of every new movie is about
the last 20
like the way that Rocky's always started
with like Rocky basically the previously
on Rocky
well before anyone ever do that on
tonight
I am in I mean we all are I don't know
anybody I've seen a few people on
Twitter who were just like yeah like I
understand people like it but it's not
doing much for me let's not do anything
for you we're all gonna go you guys it's
also like come on dude like it's Harley
Quinn and the Joker and they now they're
putting Batman in there so you're
[ __ ] like it's like getting another
bat it's like getting another Batman
movie you know what I'm saying that's
that's like when were we ever getting
two Batman movies in one year before so
[ __ ] jaded everybody is dude they
forgot about the lien Batman like years
between Batman
oh yeah Batman and now that got Batman
in his own movie and then the throne
Batman in this movie you're getting more
Batman shake a [ __ ] yeah we had to
wait like three years for Batman and
Robin yes I did know what I got sir no
did not wanted I ordered better than
those it's it's a great time to be alive
when they stick more but when Batman
jumps into the water with a rebreather
and that's not even like hey man that's
our third act a big action sequence in
the new Batman movie yeah like that's
just a [ __ ] throwaway thing it's our
James Bond teaser it's kind of like for
all we know it's a tiny piece of the
movie like it ain't even the main plot
or anything like that that's not [ __ ]
confident they are they're like here's a
few frames of Batman's swimming last
time you saw that was in [ __ ] Batman
Forever and you hated it then but you're
gonna love it now we're taking it back
they did bring me back they reclaimed it
in that trailer just that shot of him
[ __ ] swan dive and often I don't know
if that's a swan dive but like just that
[ __ ] or curtsy
and then go diving in the water and [ __ ]
like that a man and a cape and the water
is visually interesting but logically
stupid you could take that off buddy
a lot of drag on those things before you
know I don't want to say anything I'll
be an internet story about like Smith
[ __ ] hates the Suicide Squad you
cannot say that [ __ ] love this
trailer so much smithy swimming
yeah you can say that boy I [ __ ] do
man sharks yeah I even ate pool swimming
yeah talking to Mike to the other side
it's tiresome send me a bladder someone
dragged me to the other side throw me a
rope
Jay come drag me will you live with my
stretch marks there it is
that's [ __ ] the Suicide Squad trailer
man in it we died ugh I'll give it ten
out of [ __ ] time you I'm like eight
out of ten we're cautiously optimistic
night I'll Jack it down nine point five
out of ten it's not really fair you
didn't play the average is very very
[ __ ] it's big big trailers out there
kids man big trailer because not that
was satisfying his [ __ ] so get ready
squad rules [ __ ] it's all happiness was
it August 5th mmm some like that right
in time for my birthday
yeah a second I'll be celebrating three
days later was suicide well you gonna
have I got chuck-e-cheese party [ __ ]
yeah
what a good idea Batman Batman
chuck-e-cheese party right in if you
want to attend that's all we got kids
that's all we got from Batman this week
up Kevin Smith mark barnard and come
back next week same fat time same fat
channel SModcast calm or youtube.com
slash Kevin Smith
hey man it's me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder